[Musica]
voglio condividere con te un segreto
un segreto che
cambierà che modellerà il tuo futuro
e il futuro della tua salute
questo fenomeno di ringiovanimento
ha aiutato i nostri antenati
a vivere una vita lunga e sana
purtroppo
abbiamo cambiato il nostro  stili di vita circa 40 anni
fa
e abbiamo perso
questo fenomeno di ringiovanimento
e abbiamo iniziato a sviluppare malattie
croniche in giovane età
nonostante i trilioni di dollari che
spendiamo per l'assistenza sanitaria
i tassi di diabete cancro alzheimer
e malattie autoimmuni
continuano a crescere
il segreto che voglio condividere con voi
è che c'è un potenziale nel tuo corpo
per ringiovanire te stesso
per guarire te stesso
c'è un dottore dentro ognuno di noi
e c'è un modo per risvegliare questo dottore
e il modo per farlo è attraverso lo stress
lascia che ti faccia un esempio
se per sbaglio ti tagli  la tua pelle in
cucina usando un coltello
non hai bisogno di chiamare un medico
non hai bisogno di prendere una pillola
hai bisogno di mettere un cerotto
e il corpo
chiama  cellule
e chiede loro di ringiovanire,
rigenerarsi e guarire in
modo che, in risposta allo stress fisico, il
nostro corpo
richieda il ringiovanimento cellulare e la guarigione
questo è il segreto che voglio condividere
con voi
circa 20 anni fa
ricercatori dell'Università della California del Sud
sotto la guida di  il professor Walter
Longo
uno scienziato italiano
ha scoperto un livello di stress molto più alto,
uno stress che può ridurre una rigenerazione totale del corpo
e che lo stress è il digiuno non è un
digiuno qualsiasi di
cui tutti avete sentito parlare del
digiuno intermittente o del digiuno per poche ore
questo non basta in quanto stress per
rigenerarti
il ​​digiuno che ringiovanisce e
ringiovanisce le tue cellule si chiama
digiuno prolungato o digiuno per due o
tre o quattro o cinque giorni non
vuoi andare oltre i cinque giorni
perché fallirai il tuo corpo e  non
vuoi scendere sotto i due o tre giorni
perché non ti rigenererai
non ti chiamerai per
ringiovanire
questo io  è un digiuno periodico o prolungato
dato che oggi siamo a modena
la capitale mondiale delle corse automobilistiche
ti faccio un esempio
ispirato alle corse automobilistiche per aiutarti a
capire questo fenomeno di
ringiovanimento con il digiuno
quindi immagina di essere il pilota e  sei
in una corsa automobilistica e stai andando forte
e sei preoccupato che il motore si
surriscaldi e sei preoccupato che
le ruote si consumino cosa
puoi fare per aiutare
bene la tua macchina puoi togliere il piede dal  gas
e tu prendi la pressione del motore
la stessa cosa che possiamo fare al nostro corpo
se stai conducendo uno stile di
vita malsano cosa puoi fare puoi mangiare
meglio puoi fare esercizio puoi stressarti di
meno puoi dormire meglio
tutte queste cose
come dentro  l'auto da corsa aiuterà l'
auto tutta la carrozzeria a durare più a lungo ma comunque
la cosa migliore che puoi fare all'auto
è portarla a un pit stop
quando vai al pit stop tutti i
meccanici vengono
all'auto cambiano le ruote loro  cambia l'
olio che hanno messo  più
benzina riparano l'auto
ed è esattamente come funziona il digiuno sul
tuo corpo è un pieno potere di
rigenerazione e ringiovanimento cellulare
lo chiamiamo scientificamente autofagia
e l'autofagia ha vinto il premio nobel in
medicina nel 2016.
ora abbiamo un problema per
chi può digiunare  da tre a cinque giorni
è molto difficile ed è rischioso per
molti,
ma questo è quando la scienza viene in nostro
soccorso,
lo stesso team dell'università della
California meridionale che ha scoperto il
potere del digiuno
ci ha portato anche una grande
scoperta scientifica nutrizionale hanno sviluppato un
digiuno che imita  nutrizione
è una
nutrizione a base vegetale naturale a cinque valli
che hanno sviluppato tecnologicamente
per nutrire il nostro corpo ma mantiene le cellule
in modalità di digiuno
e questo è controverso ma è una
svolta scientifica,
quindi questa nutrizione è un alimento di cinque giorni
che arriva al nostro corpo
che  ci aiuta a nutrirci e nutrirci
ma quando i nutrienti arrivano alle
cellule non vengono rilevati dai radar
del  cellule e per la prima volta in assoluto
abbiamo una grande svolta nutrizionale
chiamata il digiuno che imita la nutrizione
questa nutrizione ha ottenuto numerosi
brevetti in tutto il mondo, incluso un
brevetto per aiutarci a
vivere a lungo e rigenerarci
ciò di cui sono entusiasta
ora è il digiuno è la conformità è fattibile
è fattibile
delle persone che consumano la
nutrizione a digiuno di cinque giorni lo fanno con successo
e questo ha aperto la porta per testarlo su
più malattie croniche
pensa al diabete
la più grande malattia del mondo
come si sviluppa il diabete aumenti
di
peso sviluppi insulino-resistenza e poi
diventi diabetico
cosa ha fatto la medicina per il
diabete suggerisce di dare una pillola a ogni
paziente che deve consumare ogni
giorno della sua vita
e poi alla fine della sua vita
iniziano a iniettarsi insulina
poiché il diabete è una malattia di origine alimentare
non  ha senso
invertirlo e curarlo con
un'alimentazione sana e ancora meglio con un digiuno che
imita l'
alimentazione tardiva  Il primo studio clinico sulla
nutrizione a digiuno mostra
un
aumento del 700 nelle possibilità di remissione
e regressione del diabete rispetto alla
medicina attuale
cosa sul cancro il
cancro è una cellula che si sviluppa e si
replica
velocemente, cresce abbastanza velocemente e va ovunque
nel corpo
il modo migliore per rallentare  il cancro potrebbe
essere un
cancro a digiuno
perché il cancro ha bisogno di crescere velocemente ha
bisogno di nutrienti e se lo fai morire di fame e
poi lo colpisci con la chemioterapia o la
terapia ormonale i recenti studi clinici stanno
dimostrando che la nutrizione a digiuno può
aumentare
l'efficacia e la potenza della
corrente  chemio e terapia ormonale
malattie autoimmuni
si verificano quando i globuli bianchi del
corpo attaccano un organo
i recenti studi e la
nutrizione a digiuno
dimostrano che in realtà il digiuno non
tollera una rapida replicazione delle
cellule autoimmuni induce la rigenerazione dei globuli bianchi
e aiuta a  danneggiare l'organo per
ringiovanire
questo è molto personale per me
perché ho iniziato la mia professione  per tutta
la vita come medico
e sono andato a medicina per curare i pazienti
per aiutarli a invertire le loro malattie,
ma subito dopo aver iniziato a praticare
ho scoperto che sto dando loro una pillola
o molte pillole che devono prendere per
il resto della loro vita
non c'era soluzione per l'
annullamento, venivano abbonati ogni giorno
una pillola
e la mia grande domanda era
se questo medicinale funziona
perché devono riempirlo ogni mese,
quindi ho lasciato la medicina
e sono andato a studiare politica sanitaria e
salute pubblica
per sostenere  per una salute vero
sistema sanitario non un sistema di assistenza ai malati
e sono andato alla ricerca di una soluzione una soluzione di
medicina dello stile di vita
per aiutare i pazienti con malattie croniche a
raggiungere con successo la remissione e la
regressione delle loro malattie
ho avuto la fortuna di imbattermi nella
scienza del digiuno e del digiuno
imitando la nutrizione e ho reso la mia
passione portarla a tutti in tutto il mondo
ed è per questo che sono oggi alla
piattaforma ted per informarvi tutti
ab  scopri questo segreto il
segreto dell'autoguarigione del potere di
ringiovanimento e ripristino attraverso il digiuno
che oggi puoi ottenere con
un'alimentazione che imita il digiuno
è come portare l'auto al pit stop
se vuoi adottare uno
stile di vita basato sulla longevità fai il digiuno che imita
nutrizione due o tre volte all'anno
e se hai una condizione di salute
la recente scienza sulla
nutrizione che imita il digiuno sta mostrando un impatto molto potente e molto
potenziale sulle malattie
croniche volevo cambiare la tua vita oggi con
queste informazioni e ti ringrazierò
per il tuo tempo
[Musica]
tu